thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to find
out how you can get a 20 discount on
their courses in science and mathematics
recently i watched the 2004 movie the
day after tomorrow for the first time
out of a sense of morbid curiosity if
you've not seen it good it's a disaster
movie about abrupt climate change
melting of arctic sea ice destabilizes
the thermo-haline circulation a conveyor
belt that transports warm water from the
equator to the north atlantic where it
warms the land around it before sinking
into the deep ocean
in the movie this current is turned off
causing an outbreak of extremely cold
air across the northern hemisphere that
creates supercell storms bringing in a
new ice age whilst watching i made a few
notes on the scientific accuracy of the
film which i wrote on this piece of
paper here lots has been said about the
scientific inaccuracies of this film a
new ice age wouldn't begin in a matter
of days the iss doesn't spin like that
the movie doesn't know how climate
models work and how does a single
climatologist afford this house you can
read stuff about the climatological
accuracy of this film elsewhere suffice
to say it's incredibly inaccurate but
there was something in it that was so
nonsensical that it was like watching
water flow uphill and yet no one is
talking about this so in this video i'm
going to talk about what that mistake
was and correct it and show you what
would actually happen which is still
kind of cool and actually still in
keeping with a disaster movie the
physics breaking problem is in this clip
the storm's rotation is pulling
supercooled air all the way down from
the upper troposphere shouldn't the air
warm up before it reaches ground level
it should but it doesn't the air is
descending too rapidly when this storm
is over
we'll be in a new ice age
we see this happening later on in the
film when the empire state building
freezes solid from the top down with
temperatures as low we're told in
another scene as minus 150 freedom units
or approximately minus 100 degrees
celsius which is cold enough to freeze
helicopter fuel that's not how physics
works right atmospheric physics 101
let's say you have a bunch of air at a
certain temperature how could that
temperature change well you could do two
things add heat to the air or do work on
the air both are important here the heat
one is easier to understand you may have
learned in school but there are three
mechanisms by which heat can be
transferred to an object conduction
convection and radiation conduction is
when stuff touches other stuff and makes
it warmer it's like thermal energy being
directly handed from one substance to
another convection is when warm stuff
moves to colder stuff and mixes with it
the thermal energy is moved by a carrier
and radiation is when stuff eats energy
in the form of electromagnetic radiation
to other stuff which then absorbs it the
energy moves itself as a photon it
doesn't need a carrier in the atmosphere
conduction just isn't a concern air does
not conduct heat well convection however
is what dominates the heat transfer on
short time scales warmer air mixing with
cooler air while oversimplifying
radiation is what dominates on the
longer time scales it's what ultimately
determines climate shouldn't the air
warm up before it reaches ground level
it should but it doesn't the air is
descending too rapidly
if the air were to move extremely
rapidly down through the atmosphere then
as i've already said conduction isn't a
concern and radiation acts on longer
time scales so we could pretty safely
ignore that too conceivably the air
could move in such a way that convection
wasn't significant either if the
descending air mass was particularly
fast and coherent so let's say for the
sake of argument that there's no heat
transfer at all no convection takes
place and the air mass is what we call
thermally isolated but even if the air
in the clip is thermally isolated two
problems firstly the air in the upper
troposphere where they say in the film
the air is from isn't minus 100 degrees
celsius it's probably more like minus 70
degrees celsius at the polar regions
above that the air temperature actually
increases with altitude before gradually
falling again in the mesosphere i've
made a whole video about this for air to
be cold enough to freeze helicopter fuel
it would have to come from the top of
the mesosphere the coldest part of the
atmosphere at about 80 kilometers above
the surface the second problem however
and this is the water flowing uphill
part
has to do with
work as you get higher in the atmosphere
the air pressure decreases this is
because air pressure is just the weight
of air above you and so the higher up
you go the less weight there is above
you and so less pressure that means
however that if a chunk of air were to
descend from the upper atmosphere to the
lower atmosphere it would be moving from
an area of lower pressure to an area of
higher pressure and as air isn't some
solid incompressible thing
that means that the air would be
compressed by that additional pressure
in doing so performs work on the air and
for a system where no heat transfer is
taking place as we've already
established doing work on the system
means the temperature will change
specifically it will increase
we call this adiabatic heating and it's
actually what largely determines the
temperature profile in the lowest part
of the atmosphere as air rises it cools
adiabatically like this note that the
difference between these two curves is
almost entirely just because there's
water in the atmosphere which
kind of makes all the thermodynamics a
bit more complicated so conversely if
you were to take air from the top of the
troposphere and squidge it down to the
surface it wouldn't be very cold in fact
it would be very hot depending on where
you are between 50 and 100 degrees
celsius i can say that with absolute
certainty because the temperature of a
bit of air if you were to squidge it
down to the surface is actually a
variable that we use quite frequently in
atmospheric science we call it the
potential temperature and it's useful
for a variety of calculations we
construct maps like this where you can
see the average potential temperature
with latitude on the horizontal axis and
height on the vertical note that towards
the middle of the stratosphere the
potential temperature is about a
thousand kelvin or 700 degrees celsius
so if you were to somehow drag air down
from higher up in the atmosphere to the
empire state building it wouldn't freeze
it because it's not enough to just
consider the heat transfer in the
atmosphere you also have to think about
the work done in moving a compressible
gas like air from a low pressure
environment to a high pressure
environment near the surface air from
the upper atmosphere then would not
freeze the empire state building it
would roast it and if you took the i
from high enough in the atmosphere would
actually melt it in fact it would not
look too dissimilar from a shot in
another far better roland emmerich movie
picture the scene you're you and you've
just finished watching this video about
applying physics to the movies about how
the world really works and you'd like to
learn more about this but you don't
fancy committing to full-time education
because that's a big financial
commitment and it sounds a bit well
boring well you're in luck because
brilliant this video sponsor is all
about making subjects in science maths
and computer science interesting and
interactive brilliant is a website and
app that improves your scientific and
problem-solving skills by introducing
you to new ideas and then immediately
getting you to apply them the emphasis
here is very much on trying not being
correct after all if you get an answer
to a question wrong
what's the worst that happens you just
improve for next time and learn from the
experience
no judgment brilliant offers interactive
expertly written courses from middle
school to graduate school level across a
huge range of subjects everything from
pre-algebra to computational biology and
i must say includes a really good course
on classical mechanics if you're in
education brilliant brings the topics
you've learned about in the classroom to
gorgeous interactive life well if you've
left full-time education behind then
brilliant especially the app allows you
to keep your problem-solving skills
sharp and lets you pursue your
scientific curiosity to get started for
free visit brilliant.org simon clark or
click the link in the description and
the first 200 people will get 20 off
brilliant annual premium subscription
for themselves or for a student in their
life with thanks to brilliant for
sponsoring this video and for being well
brilliant thank you so much for watching
the video thanks also must go to my old
professor miles allen at oxford who
introduced me to this scene in the film
years ago i hadn't seen the movie there
but he introduced me to it and
it stuck in my brain i knew i had to
make a video about it someday so thanks
miles here's some recommended viewing
from me next if you enjoyed this video
please do pop it a like and let me know
in the comments because i'd love to do
more stuff that mixes movies and science
kind of my jam anyway thank you so much
for watching i hope you enjoyed and i'll
see you in the next one